es gibt also immer wieder neue gründe
für im food in deutschland bei denen die
jetzt eigentlich geimpft werden sollten
bei denen sich impftermine ganz aktuell
verschieben wie zb in nordrhein
westfalen wo wir ja berichtet haben dass
dort aktuell ein impfstoff für
erstimpfung besteht aber auch bei denen
die los impfen wollen also vor allen
dingen bei den ärzten dort die sich
immer häufiger fragen ja wo ist er denn
nun der impfstoff und genau darüber
wollen wir sprechen mit denen menschen
die los impfen wollen die volle
engagement sind in dieser corona krise
und das sind sven goldbach der chef
eines pflegedienstes der uns
zugeschaltet ist christine liedtke die
ein ganzes pflegeheim leitet und der
krankenpfleger thomas harris lassen sie
uns mit ihnen gerne anfangen in allen
schönen guten abend alles wie groß ist
die im food mittlerweile bei ihnen die
input ist es muss losgehen ich bin
sollte ich irgendwann bestimmt wurden
aber ich hoffe dass es bald losgeht frau
lüke bei ihnen im wird geheim das sind
ja die ersten die dran sind können sie
da sozusagen vollzug melden ist bei
ihnen durchgeimpft ja wir hatten ja
waren gleich am ersten wochenende nach
weihnachten dran und haben jetzt die
zweite impfung erhalten was nach wie vor
leider umgekehrt ist ist was wir mit den
bewohnern machen die jetzt nach und nach
bei uns neu einziehen denn 70 prozent
meiner bewohnerschaft wechselt übers
jahr das heißt mit der herdenimmunität
ist es dann auch nicht allzu lange hin
deswegen warten wir schon sehnsüchtig
auf weiter den impfstoff herr goldbach
sie habe ich gerade schon gesagt
leighton einen mobilen palliativpflege
dienst haben sie schon kontakt zu dem
impfstoff gehabt und zu kämpfen
also wir haben das große glück gehabt
dass die hälfte unseres personals
relativ schnell dran gekommen ist war
der anderen hälfte ist es dazu dass sie
keine termine mehr bekommen und auch
termine für patienten die ihr machen
wollten sind nicht mehr zu bekommen hier
in hamburg bei uns war das impfzentrum
fall ist die hotline massiv überlastet
und online wir nicht mehr durchkommen
was fehlt ihnen der goldbacher aktuell
seitens der bundesregierung verbrauchen
sie mehr unterstützung was kommt ihnen
zu kurz also was ich finde was eindeutig
fehlt ist die kommunikation und
transparenz dass wir sozusagen wirklich
darüber informiert werden was los ist
auch durch die länder also nicht nur
durch die bundesregierung auch durch die
länder
das wurde uns impfstoff angepriesen dass
er jetzt da ist dass wir uns alle also
gerade auch in der ambulanten
palliativversorgung wir uns relativ
schnell impfen lassen kann und
letztendlich steht die hälfte des
personals sitzt da und kommt nicht an
den impfstoff rang
ich würde mir wünschen dass man offen
damit um
geht und sagt ich entweder es gibt die
nur das gibt die nicht und wir sehen ja
ganz klar dass andere länder ist es
abartig finde israel lassen ein
wunderbares beispiel die so viele
menschen schon durchgemacht haben und da
frage ich mich warum wir das hier für
das gesundheitspersonal und wirklich für
die bedürftigen menschen das nicht
hinbekommen
fragen wir uns ja auch jeden tag und das
mittlerweile schon seit wochen helios
wir sehen auch dann wie die politik
darauf reagiert gestern die kanzlerin
die sagt ich habe keine
produktionsstätte heute der
bundesgesundheitsminister der sagt da
ländervergleiche also das geht jetzt in
dieser zeit gar nicht finden sie dass
das schönrednerei ist oder haben sie
verständnis dafür dass die politik so
reagiert also das erleben wir von der
pflege setzt seit über 30 jahren also
dass das ist der pflege viel versprochen
wird aber letztendlich nicht eingehalten
wird
wir brauchen einfach mehr lohn und
letztendlich ist es auch so dass der
flug überhaupt gar nicht zugehört wird
wenn es darum geht entscheidungen zu
treffen die die arbeit der pflege
verbessern sollen
das heißt darüber fliege gesprochen wird
da hat es pflege überhaupt gar nicht
beteiligt da sitzen an dem tisch
überhaupt keine fliegerkräfte mit die
ahnung davon haben was pflege überhaupt
ist und was das bedeutet mit menschen
umzugehen und für die da zu sein und
ihnen helfen zu wollen
von luther letzte frage an sie finden
sie die erklärung der politik
nachvollziehbar im moment dafür dass
eben der impfstoff so tröpfchenweise nur
ankommt und ist jetzt sogar in nordrhein
westfalen erst mal wieder ein impfstoff
gibt na ja den impfstoff war haben wir
hier in bayern auch und ich bin es
nutzern gewissen grad nachvollziehbar
weil man ja durchaus sieht dass es in
anderen ländern voran geht und bei uns
eben nicht und darstellt muss man schon
mal die frage stellen wer hat denn da
langfristig gedanken gemacht weil es
geht ja nicht nur um uns in den ist
eigentlich mal institutionen in den
pflegeeinrichtungen ambulanten diensten
sondern es geht auch um irgendeinen
angehörigen zwei drittel aller
pflegebedürftigen in deutschland werden
zu hause etwas sorgt auch die haben
momentan keine chance eine impfangebot
und
warten genau so sehnsüchtig dann nochmal
die nachfrage das ist die frage die ich
mir am meisten stelle wie erfahren die
denn überhaupt wann sie dran sind denn
das ist ja also die findet man ja im
ganzen land schon gar nicht wie erfahren
die dass sie dran sind mit dem impfen
die eben nicht in heimen wohnen also
eigentlich per post noch nicht versendet
worden weil man ja auch davon ausgeht
dass es jetzt im momentan noch gar nicht
so schlimm ist dass der brief nicht
angekommen ist weil es gibt ja keinen
impfstoff
also so absurd klingt es dann danke
ihnen drei für diese diskussion
sozusagen an der impf basis an der
pflege basis und für ihre eindrücke dort
wirklich vor ort herzlichen dankeschön
abend
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren